so McDonald's has this McDonald's
McResource line put Nick in front of
everything it's brilliant and this is
where they give tips lifestyle tidbits
to assist their employees and NBC News
check out the site last week and found
this article dedicated to tipping
service that their employees should give
to the people that are serving them
during the holidays so this is what
McDonald's wants their employees to be
giving to their employees for your au
pair a gift from your family or or one
week's pay plus a small gift from your
child for your housekeeper one day's pay
your pool cleaner because most people
making the seven dollars and change in
McDonald's have a pool cost of one
cleaning the article also lists holiday
tipping pointers for your dog walker
your massage therapist of course and
your personal fitness trainer just a
little bit more about numbers and money
and McDonald's CEO James Skinner made
about 14 million last year okay that's
actually not that's actually not crazy
amount in the world of CEOs but it is a
lot obviously but that breaks down to
nine thousand two hundred and forty
seven dollars per hour do you know how
long it would take the average
mcdonald's worker who makes seven
dollars and seventy three cents to make
that cool for months yeah for money this
guy makes me very full and a lot of
mcdouble workers are part-time employees
I would take eight months yeah okay so
let's just start with with that part of
it then we'll get into the specifics of
this of this type of thing but the money
breakdown and the CEO is making this
crazy man and we see every year it gets
worse and worse the the disparity
between the CEO pay and the average
worker pay just gets worse and worse is
there anything we can do to stop this i
guess they're trying even just this last
week we had these protests or they're
trying to get at least fifteen dollars
an hour and your big macs going to go up
in price a little bit because they're
not certainly they don't want to take
away his money his salary shareholder
profits we're sure exactly shareholder
profits salaries for people that you
know are obviously this guy's making 14
million dollars and somebody's trying to
survive with their nanny with the dog
walker their pool and their fitness
trainer well there
working at McDonald's obviously yeah
it's insane these people obviously did
not look before you know McDonald's well
it was a third-party person that put
this on our website we just didn't look
at it but who was the third party person
looking thinking that McDonald's workers
had an au pair all right so we'll get to
the specifics of this ridiculous thing
in a second but what can we do about
really what can we do about the CEO to
average worker pay I think it starts
with the federal minimum wage that's
that's like a beginning place because we
have so many people to lift out of
poverty and to help those people
actually participate in the economy and
when they participate in the economy in
the economy they're more likely to vote
and by voting and making sure that you
know people who actually care about them
and actually work for them and actually
share their values get into office to
make sure that when we have incentives
and subsidies that are being given away
to corporations that Congress boats on
that those people don't let those
subsidies go through right now what
would you argue to the crazy capitalists
the purists who would say well if you do
that then the dollar menu is going to
disappear and they're going to fire
everybody and replace them all with
robots what's the archives it's
absolutely [ __ ] there is no economic
data that proves that you know if the
economic data shows that when you lift
people out of poverty into the middle
class that it actually helps the economy
because that money gets circulated
throughout the economy you know wealthy
people CEOs they don't buy stuff what
they do is they maybe we'll buy some
luxury items but they'll invest the rest
and it doesn't get circulated in the
economy yeah you know when people are at
the middle class or lower you know I
think it's something like the vast
majority of Americans make sixty
thousand dollars a year or less that's a
lot of folks who will immediately put
that money back into the economy so when
you treat labor as an expense rather
than an asset that is I think the the
place where capitalism falters and
unfettered capitalism actually is a
detriment to society okay so now let's
talk about this the McResource thing
itself because obviously this is
completely insane and yes they're saying
it was a third party but they still put
it on their website it reminded me
responsible they're still response way
to rely to me the thing do you see a
couple weeks ago Walmart that Walmart
store had a
you know they were a bit yeah they
wanted people to help other walmart
employees meanwhile the two owners the
sisters that on walmart or what the two
or three richest people in america or
something like that I mean really really
crazy stuff so is there just really some
disconnect between the corporate level
of these companies like McDonald's and
then what is really happening on the
ground that they could get that this
could even happen well of course I think
there is disconnect but there's also
people i probably don't really give a
[ __ ] about their jobs you know oh here
we're making a list of things to do for
how to tip for the holidays and they
just put it on the site without even
it's like they don't even care to look
and go oh you know this probably doesn't
fit with the mcdonald's employee let's
adjust it or change it cuz god forbid
that might take some work for them to
maybe make another list then the one
that they already created using that
template you know I I think that's very
legit that we everyone sees this and you
want to get crazy see what McDonald's is
doing and that but I do think it's very
possible that what you're saying is
right that it's this is just some
mid-level person not doing there which
is together from you know stuff they
found on the internet yeah so the
inequality thing it's is there anything
else we can do for getting the the fast
food but just the general inequality
thing Obama said at home make your own
food at home I guess that well you know
people always say that if you keep that
food low it's that the lower poor people
need that food which I'm always not so
sure that that's true because for the
eight dollars that you spend at
McDonald's to get a big mac meal or
whatever it is you could go to Trader
Joe's and still get a pretty decently
healthy meal for eight dollars right
okay I mean you know when we look at say
our farm system you know we subsidize
food processors we subsidize commodities
that actually then make ingredients
cheap for the manufactured food industry
and we don't give any assistance
whatsoever to the the organics or the
ripe fruits and vegetables people you
know those those farmers don't get that
help we know it's a problem when you can
get a big mac meal for 2 99 with a large
coke with fries that are fried and then
you want a salad that's kind of healthy
that maybe have some fresh
your vegetables on it with a side of
fruit and it's ten dollars yeah okay you
can see that there's the issue your
dollar yeah you know and I think that
you know you share the information with
everybody in your network because that's
how it works you tell your friends and
family and make sure that they
understand what the issues actually are
that cheap food comes at a price and it
doesn't come at a price that's good for
you of course they're gonna do that she
care you know I think all people are
educated and they've seen all the videos
of how they processed food and stuff and
they still go here and we'll talk about
I can still get out with a bag of food
for three dollars I think a lot fewer
people are actually educated about it
than we realize you know there have been
some recent polls that show a lot of
folks really don't know about these
issues because they're too busy trying
to make ends meet and raise their kids
and you know get a good night's sleep so
they can get up again and do it all
tomorrow and they don't really have all
that information now and that's exactly
yeah and that's exactly why we've talked
many times here about all these corn
subsidies so then they put high fructose
corn syrup in everything so that sugar
is actually too expensive for coke to
put in Coke there you drinking corn
people corn